[Música]
y la luna aterrizamos en la tierra para
hablar de los problemas económicos que
afronta chile previo a estas elecciones
del 21 de noviembre este domingo que
viene para ello ya está en el estudio
daniela blandón dani bienvenida
felices viernes pues hablemos de chileno
claro que si raúl buenos días vio el
eclipse a no pues claro lo vimos aquí la
célula de acción a las 3 de la mañana
cuando llegamos aquí a trabajar
espectacular espectacular ahora sí
hablemos de chilo cómo llega el país
daniela cómo llega el país miren el
juego ya concluyeron los actos de
campaña y al tiempo que se conoció que
el producto alto al mismo tiempo se
conoció que el producto interno bruto en
el tercer trimestre creció 17,2 por
ciento frente al mismo período del año
pasado esto demuestra raúl que se está
recuperando de su peor contracción
económica en cuatro décadas que había
sufrido el año pasado sin embargo esta
nación muy dependiente de la actividad
minera está lidiando con una alta
inflación que en lo corrido del año ha
sido del 58 por ciento también con una
pobreza que cerró el año pasado en 10,8
por ciento o sea 2,1 millones de
personas la padecen y la pobreza extrema
es del 43 por ciento o unas 800.000
personas e inflación que estamos
precisamente hablando con nuestra
invitada del día nuestra primera mitad
del día pero le pregunto a mí entonces
por qué tanto descontento social en un
país que se caracteriza por tener una de
las economías más prósperas de nuestra
región pues raúl a pesar de que sí es
cierto de que que chile es uno de los
países más prósperos de américa latina
con una economía que era muy boyante
antes de la pandemia también es verdad
que es el segundo país más desigual
dentro de las naciones de la ocde o del
club de países ricos sólo después de
costa rica según la cepal que es la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe en este país el 1 por ciento
de la población concentra más de una
cuarta parte de la riqueza y muchos lo
atribuyen al modelo económico neoliberal
que tiene sus bases por supuesto el
libre mercado por ejemplo en el tema
pensional existe un sistema privado
señalado de obtener grandes beneficios y
de entregar bajos montos de jubilación y
por eso es que ya se han permitido hacer
retiros de pensiones anticipadas también
dan y hablemos de un tema que estábamos
ampliando con nuestro corresponsal en
india varón porque el gobierno de ese
país atendió finalmente los llamados de
los manifestantes después de un año y lo
que hizo es que va a por lo menos
prometió que va a eliminar tres leyes
muy polémicas que afectaban a los
agricultores esto después de un año de
protestas por parte de los granjeros que
en su momento se tornaron violentas
escuchemos
hoy he venido a decirles a todo el país
que hemos decidido retirar y derogar las
tres leyes agrícolas en la sesión del
parlamento que comienza a finales de
este mes completaremos el proceso
constitucional para derogar estas tres
leyes agrícolas de arnie kander en el
día ahora es bueno saber cómo funciona
el tema allá en libia raúl es que hoy en
día a los agricultores les venden a los
mercados mayoristas regulados por el
gobierno y les garantizan cierto precio
de sus productos la esencia de las
medidas según el ejecutivo era des
regulares de mercado para que ellos
pudieran negociar directamente sus
productos con las grandes cadenas y sin
intermediarios pero los agricultores
decían que iban a quedar a merced del
libre mercado sin garantías de que les
protegieran sus precios y pues con los
grandes que podrían devorar se los ha
hecho así están y hablemos ahora de
japón porque el gobierno lanzó un plan
millonario de reactivación económica y
no estamos hablando de poco dinero raúl
son 500.000 casi 500 mil millones de
dólares que es como dos veces el pib del
país como perú ahí le dejo es de datos
pues los estímulos para superar el
impacto de la pandemia incluyen en la
entrega de 800 63 dólares a las personas
menores de menores ingresos esta cifra
es tres veces un salario mínimo a jan
pero de donde estamos hablando y también
la van a recibir las familias por cada
hijo menor de 18 años lo que busca el
gobierno es apoyar el consumo de
productos básicos y los gastos en
educación también habrá subsidios para
el sector turístico y descuentos para
los viajeros para incentivar a que
vuelvan a salir de sus casas finalmente
entre otras medidas habrá alza salarial
para personal médico y empleados de
residencias de ancianos también para los
de las guarderías hablemos ahora desde
indicadores económicos como cerraron
como amanecen algunas bolsas bueno pues
son justamente esta ronda de estímulos
han sido bien acogida por los
inversionistas en la bolsa de tokio que
ya terminó la semana cerró con una
ganancia del 0,5 por ciento en su
principal indicador que es el nikkei y
las bolsas europeas están operando en
rojo a esta hora a mitad de la última
jornada de la semana en medio de las
preocupaciones por el repunte de casos
de kobe 19 y la cifra del día
conoce turquía no me encantaría ir
estambul yo persona ciudad fascinante
es uno de los países que tengo para ir
bueno
pero le tengo una mala noticia y es que
el 58 por ciento se desplomó solo en la
última jornada la lira turca frente al
dólar y esto para representa un nuevo
mínimo histórico después de que el banco
central redujera de nuevo las tasas de
interés es decir cada dólar cuesta
11,27 liras turcas y es que en este país
hay una altísima inflación y los
economistas dicen que la subida de
precios de combate con tasas más altas
pero el presidente recep tayyip erdogán
dice lo contrario daniela entonces
tenemos pendiente el viaje a turquía
pero vámonos de inmediato a ruanda ahí
se desarrolla el reportaje el día de hoy
también cualquiera de nuestros hombros